The Android platform is incredibly powerful. It unlocks
so many capabilities for you to exploit in
using your applications to deliver amazing delight to
your users. Now, with that incredible power comes
great responsibility, and there's two things that you
can't violate. These are two really, really important
and prime directive light constraints. The first one
is, you must be purposeful. What does that mean?
Just because an API exists in Google Play services
or because there's a thing that you can do, there's
a sensor that exists, doesn't mean that you should use
it just for that reason. Be purposeful means that, understand
how you're going to delivery delight or some use to
your user. Why does that feature or sensor need to
be in your application? And if it doesn't, don't put
it in there. Actually, be restrained in how you're creative.
And the second one is,
>> To be respectful. You need to be respectful of your user because
your application might know a lot about your user and it's really important
that you use that information to deliver delight to your user. A Contextware
application can go from being amazing to being kind of creepy pretty fast.